hello everybody my name is markiplier
say hi to Betsy that's Betsy everybody I
just unlocked her as a character and
this is action Hank a game I play to
actually impacts prime of last year it's
a lot of fun it's a 3d semi 2d style
platforming game I'll show you how it
goes in a second it's a lot like
speedrunners is except with less
competitive elements to it now I haven't
played in an online multiplayer and I'm
trying to I'll probably have to
concentrate here a little bit because
I'm not terribly good when I'm trying to
talk at the same time but just okay
never mind we're gonna start over I did
not do any of that well I was I was
practicing beforehand but I wasn't
talking while I was doing it it's
amazing how much trying to think of the
words you're trying to say interrupts
the flow of what you're doing but if you
think about like how sonic was way early
in the day stamina was made that if you
think about how sonic was way early in
the day
before it got really weird I mean just
see any of the game grumps play through
a sonic to get an idea what I'm talking
about here but BAM okay so I got a new
personal best this is all what the game
is about it's about running through
these levels that you can actually
create yourself or you can play with
other people and I'll show you how you
can play with other people by playing a
level that I did just a little bit ago
to unlock Betsy and that was in Betsy's
challenge over here so the town locked
other characters you have to actually
beat him in a race so oh god now that's
two of them hi hi Betsy
yeah that's that's not gonna be in my
nightmares tonight thank you very much
for that
okay so Betsy is good but I beat her
because apparently I'm better
so you're just okay this oh god so you
press the left trigger to slide it's
very intuitive very simple very fun
style of game with a lot of really
creative out I didn't know that right
dammit dammit dammit dammit dammit
dammit
dagnabbit dammit dammit fudge I'm gonna
give this just everybody concentrate
here everybody wish me that's like a
spirit bomb you gotta believe in me or
else
gonna happen I wouldn't raise my arm in
the air but it kind of impedes my
ability to beat Betsy into the ground
okay so you got a tinier slides
correctly us you're just gonna go
nowhere and not build up any speed which
is what you need
so sometimes it's better to like jump
beforehand before you go into a slide
sometimes it's better to jump afterwards
bow is that a personal best AB damn it I
did way better on the last one baby
going so that's what like to get the
basics of the game is get out of here
that's C I don't want to look at your
face anymore ah hi Betsy
I'm sorry about everything I said please
don't murder me in my sleep
Betsy knows when you're awake Betsy sees
if you've been bad or good so we got for
Betsy's sake anyway the actual story of
it and the character that I'm not
playing right now is actually Hank
himself but Betsy was just too good to
pass up so I kind of didn't do action
I'll go although Hank in a second
because there's a lot of characters that
can be unlocked through the game and I
remember when I was playing it back in
packs it was really polished the thing
about the game is it looks really cool
and it's actually really well done so I
like it a lot it's really free and fun
and flowing and oh I got a gold knockout
of silver dammit but I did better than
brutally swag achill and eat my diction
suck on that dudes how about that I'm
good at this game he'll do Wow okay oh
yeah I lost too much speed damn it
dagnabbit damn it damn it dad nabbit
okay yeah I can pick this up cuz if you
time your jumps correctly on like the
ship I'm sight-reading this entire level
but if you time your jumps correctly oh
god don't slide upwards it's a rookie
mistake yeah there we go there we go
that sucked
Oh sucked okay did I still beat the
other guys yes I'm still better than
them I suck I wish I could play them in
multiplayer because I would totally rock
their world right now the thing about
this game is that it's really fun and
it's hard like I love playing indie
games and I know that I've kind of
gotten in a slump of playing not like
the best indie games possible but
anytime I get to an indie game that I
actually thoroughly enjoy and I get a
lot of fun out of and when I'm done with
this review I'm actually going to be
playing this game
myself for a long time because it's
crazy fun like just being totally honest
I'm not being paid to review us in any
way what the hell is this okay uh oh
come on
um piss balls and ass Jesus oh come on
ah fine screw it god damn it I'll start
over at the beginning and I know oh I
know one of the even cooler things is
that there's an unlockable Sonic costume
for Hank once you once I get back to
Hank I'll show you what I mean it's uh
kind of stupid a little bit it's a
little bit stupid but that's what this
game is all about being a little bit
stupid okay here he does it dumber
how in the hell okay all right okay and
then back down into the speed yes okay
there we go that's how you're supposed
to do it yay I'm good
we got a silver how the hell I ever get
to get a gold yet but did I do better
than ah how did he do better than me I'm
so low ranked dammit I would love to
play this multiplayer han let me see if
I can get multiplayer actually it's no
one else playing with me am I by myself
again
god dammit yeah I did it good for me I
did a thing by myself
hooray no thank you Jesus okay so
there's no one playing this game right
now and that's actually a tragedy
because this game is really fun like
unbelievably fun hang on I got a switch
okay so this is Hank and Hank used to be
an awesome toy before he got a little
bit of a Pudge going on his Bell Bell no
no no no no no no no no no no no no get
back
thank you I wanted to hang and I know
there's a sonic costume for Hank if I
can find it Jesus
and actually in the game you can build
your own levels that's another really
cool thing about this there's a lot of
like customization that you could do for
both your character and the world that
you play it and I'm all thanks just a
little bit more unwieldy than the other
ones coming war bit Oh
like the whole idea is that you're a toy
by the way I don't know if anyone picked
up on that but I am indeed a toy and
whoa
okay so there there are some like there
are some like benefits to sliding up in
certain places oh yes is that a gold yes
all right yes I finally got a gold I've
never gotten the gold before I love that
suck that dick Shan yeah I did it I beat
him I'm so happy
so now I got another a challenge mode
that I can unlock so I can oh god I
don't think I want to be boxing Betty
Betsy ah are you doing there you're
looking good you looking real good okay
this is race I won't try to beat you too
badly cuz apparently you're not a very
good boxer I bet you're not even a good
runner either they were dad even what
what whoa where oh I got my butt caught
on the lip whoa there we go oh yes yes
come on come on come on baby we're
neck-and-neck
whoa yes oh boy come on baby come on
yes come on oh I gotta win this for
mother me Oh God Jesus yes wow I did it
knockout Betsy yeah that's how you get
the skins cuz you get the skins by
unlocking the other challenge but this
is only like five characters so you can
actually do god this game is fun oh man
I love this game this game is awesome
you guys have totally try this I'll get
there just coming for a walk cuz I love
this Kim and a BG chicken feed yeah
everybody tell diction like a Twitter
say I beat him in action Hank all over
the place so there's a lot of levels
that you can play and there's a lot of
different areas that you can go to
obviously and obviously I haven't played
this before so if I suck that's not my
fault
it's entirely the game because I have
not experienced any of it yet whoa Jesus
oh cool God the level design is just so
intricate in the way that it all spins
around it's all still in the room like
whoever has a room like this must have
been the cool kid in school
oh it's so cool Oh what I wouldn't have
done for a little oh god it's so cool
I did a gold again yes god I love it
okay alright so I'm gonna stop here
because obviously it's gonna be the same
I love this game it is awesome I loved
it when I played it at PAX and I'm sorry
that it took me so long to play it here
but try it for yourself I don't think
it's very much money on Steam but if
it's too much it's too much but
definitely try to get your hands on in
some way and find me a multiplayer I'm
gonna be playing multiplayer for a while
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video on the warning look stop
everything gonna give it to you okay I
didn't have enough time but you were
lucky